this video is brought to you by expressvpn
and Shopify people more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to kick off the what if season 2 journey joined
here with the man the myth the legend the koi
the JRE how you doing buddy holidays are here
and so is what if I am so excited to be covering
this with you John is not with us I promised him
earlier this year that he would have a little
bit time off from filming and this is allowing
us to uh do a couple of thinks that way he could
have the holidays you know Greg and Koy don't get
time off we don't get from the filming we must
be on camera at all times guys you know what to
do please go ahead leave a like on this video
that would be extremely appreciated also be
sure to subscribe click the notification Bell
cuz Coy and I are going to be covering all of
what F season dose and thank you to prepper for
helping us set it down these highlights lastly
massive thank you to all who have joined us at
our patreon page over there you get the full
length reat watch along where you sync up with
your own copy of what if and John and I cover
several things exclusiv with highlights and watch
alongs included Coy you ready so ready let's do
it
ominous ooh cool Blade Runner Blade
Runner Vib immediate Blade Runner
oh wow really Blade Runner to xandor
xandor a place where everyone's luck
eventually runs out oh is this
the nebula episode must be even
yand oh sweet it looks great someone did
this to him obviously yes didn't do it to
himself the question is why no damn it come
on gra there's only five things in could have
G nebula you can step away from the body
the real cops are here damn novacore oh
she's part of the novacore oh yeah yeah she got
the chest P she's like yeah already cracked the
case huh I don't need black ordered trash
telling me how to do my job former black
order I earn my stars here same as you she's
got a perfect Noir voice for this character
type is there a problem Corman this is xandor
all we got are problems yes the Dark Side of
xandor wow they straight up just said we're
going to do Blade Runner what if we did Blade
Runner with nebula okay I'm down time space
reality it's more than a man path Howard the
Duck is coming he's got to be here ta came back
for this and Ponder the question why what is damn
it who is so close in this universe Ronin the
accuser betrayed Thanos oh cool Titan's thirst
for power had met its match and in his fall he
took nebula's Sister Sister along with him so
alternate ending for Guardians of the Galaxy in
a way yeah if he' succeeded a drift in the ruins
of my past until someone saw the light in me
I really love the music in this episode so far
compassion and kindness is that Glen Close did
they get Clen close come back in voice take my
hand yes I swore the novacore oath seek the
light be the light never St from his that's
cool I like this she always needed something to
belong to yeah she's isolated her whole life so
finding a family Ronan and his forces attacked
bringing zandar to the verge of Destruction
he became Thanos yeah effectively fire up the
shield generator she locked down xandar behind
an impenetrable planetary Shield like Iron Man
wanted to xandar was saved for the time being
but at what cost I find this more effective
than the planet that was destroyed in the
Marvel I'm just saying immediately immediately
5 years in isolation has brought out the worst
in all of us still hope or no hope I took an
oath I'm not going to lie I'm really digging
this Coy yeah this blun isting sci-fi film new
art it's pretty awesome also it feels like what
Marvel was doing phase one of making it specific
GTH and Saul wasted their time hunting for the
Killer's weapon when they really should have
been looking for the victims yandu and I had
a past and some memories to go with it where's
the whistle Arrow you and I make quite the team
huh yeah you and I nebie we make fight the team
it's like Star Wars guys oh it's R2D2 but it's
summoning the arrow I think it's going to get
it to come back through that whistle there we
go awesome that's cool to utilize her skill sets
that we know and turn her into a detective Ive
yeah and her voice is so Noir based whoa oh
yandu what did you get into yandu was trying
to do something good there are no records of
these schematics in any archive on zandar not
even on the shadow Network negative thank you
for your inquiry the bleakness actually feels
palpable and the weight in the animated
characters feels I don't know I connect
more definitely Xander's on the brink yandu
got himself caught up with some dark Forces
On The Rise xandar only has until dawn I did
find something at the crime scene but it seems
yandu gave his life to protect it do you trust
her Glenn Close yeah never she hunts Dalmations
Greg you have a
warrant yeah Blood Rave it's cool to turn
it into a cyber Punk world like I like
xandar going dark it's a really interesting
take of the whole thing it yeah there's got
to be Easter eggs here reference Howard the
coming must be point out Groot Groot where's
Howard is that Drax
yeah hey rollers table but feir warning
he does not like to be buzzed when he's
on a hot streak is Howard the Duck the one in
I hope he's the High Roller so bad Hey Howard
yes I'm running a casino things are great and
speaking of great waitress could you bring us
some small bites for the reflective woman over
here or do you just eat megabytes I love how
much his character has evolved in the MCU too
Howard the Ducks actually got a great world if
you have this Arrow I'm guessing yandu finally
turned a paler shade of blue he gave his life to
protect this I ran these schematics through every
archive on xandar but nothing could I do them
what is it that's what I asked you're the
detective that's why I'm ask this is a
really good back and forth that's an old Citywide
Mainframe core it's a unit b42 I believe I didn't
think there were many of those left how the hell
would you know that I know all sorts of things I'm
more than just a pretty face you know what's in
it sanitation department metadata unpaid parking
tickets Rush Hour statistics even an actual
kitchen sink go back one unpaid parking tickets
not that Rush our statistics source code for
the shield generator looks like someone might be
trying to take down the planetary Shield if this
episode is a testament to what the rest of the
season is I need to get into that main frame and
destroy those codes places like that not everyone
who goes in out many of the people who enter these
premises end up dead tiger loves play corg so much
I can see him staying but not to direct no oh yeah
absolutely no matter where it takes me oh cool nor
fade I'd need someone with a rep for breaching
highend security someone who' infil zarian
systems before it' be cool if she te up with him
outside of Guardians Corman nebula y Rog ah Jud
law so you know me no mus no fuss I'd watch this
show a this show nebula yes nula is great I need
someone who knows their way around xandarian
security and you thought of me I arrested you
for it didn't I but if you'd rather stay here
I'm open to other recommendations this feels
like animatrix [__] it does that's exactly
what it feels like containment in D repeat
containment like it's actually building the World
by building a new world I love it yeah there's
like real composition and a distinct style to
this episode yeah it's directed give me some
credit just like in Guardians when they did
the the breakout and now they're using this
clever Ploy a sweet I love these
yeah Matt Reef shots score again
great if what if becomes one of my favorite
phase five I know right unheard of you took
an oath and this is what it takes to keep it
can't say it looks like that from where I'm
sitting oh I don't need you to understand I
just need you to live up to your reputation
she's like a combination of Harrison Ford and
Ryan Gosling from blade runers which is what I
want in nebula Noir you do realize I don't
have any tools with me man blade 249 great
editing 2200 stories that's a long way down I
didn't break you out of jail to point out the
obvious it doesn't need to take all night cool he
knew that it's like it's it's like the Multiverse
why did you stop Live Wire little early in the
night to fry your circuits don't you think yo
nebula's hot in this episode love that got got
to admit man a jesica rabbit kind of way core
overheating oh was that your clever plan give me
some credit I hope you like working underwater
that's how it's going to cool the court well I
I like how nonreactive nebula is like normally
she just gets like Teen Angst angry a lot
and here she's just she has that coldness
about her that I how we met her and there's
a little more confidence I like it a lot I
think empathy caused her to waver her confidence
which is she doesn't have yet like she's part of
a team but she's not like soft she's normally
more seething at the teeth and rage and so I
like this portrayal a lot actually of her San
main frame corol impressive the architect with
thanos's gone you wouldn't have as much be rage
about so it's interesting that Arc how that would
go Omega class cybernetic organism detected
you should follow your advice compatibility
approved Jack in Neo the animatrix
commence connection connection sequence bad
ass whoa lawn mower man she's downloading
the whole thing well I like how that warp
shot happened oh that's so cool source files
deleted now it's all up there Jesus God actually
I think I can put that source code to better
you you son of a [__] oh no you've gotone
soft log out sequence stalled system compromised
system overheating oh no they're going to kill
her off you don't have to worry about xandar
anymore Ronin has big plans for it come on
nebula now she won't overheat
oh she going go back to her
rage but no no it it was just red because of
the computer system she took rage
not cuz she's evil that helped us
visually I absolutely love
it it feels like an anime
character whoa does she need to breathe Glen
Close Glen Close betrayed it's you I knew that
blast wouldn't kill her she always has been
a Survivor she kills dations this was all a
setup all so you could start an invasion
yeah there's just no shame in surrender
and what else Ronin promised to keep me in
charge in exchange for my cooperation greed
is evil you've been using me this whole
time you're a machine what did you expect
fight back finish her and make sure you melt
down the pieces when you're done yes ma'am oh
what a cruel way I hate when people talk
about nebula like that what a waste down
yeah yeah come on
nebula get up nebula good get
him damn man the expression they've
brought this time around to finish this
yes oh I love the lines too very very anime yeah
it's very anime I'm calling it boys
colan nebula End of Watch End of
Watch I got to say especially firing and
especially compared to the last season this
actually looks like comic book panels you
know like the framing of it it doesn't just
look like a cartoon show this this actually
looks like a comic book which adds to that
anime oh my God damn that one eye Terminator
look oh oh she's getting back in tune with
the r paper but it's uncuttable paper cuz it's
made of rock amazing stupid say I told you so
but your head's bashed in so you wouldn't
remember I'm fine I just need a drink and
guns I don't even think we could
Pawn you for party I said I'm fine
oh jackpot this is bad
those aren't supposed to pay
out more Howard the Duck Season five of
Marvel you see an elium I have it's a little
bit like that but the planet the rich the poor
Moon There She is welcome back to the land of
the living there was a thck in there where I
was thinking what am I going to sing at her
funeral about those guns you know military
grade sure to kill which I'm not saying I do
it's my favorite hour of the duck killing it
the people of xandar are going to suffer drink
more Nova Prime will take your liquor don't
drink more no rock paper [Laughter] scissors
just the delivery energy of Howard the Duck
and her straightforward Cadence so fun and
then rock paper scissors is is genius yeah
oh did not see that look at that Guardian
team why is this episode so good Howard with
the comic accurate Howard with the bandana
if this was an apparent cor and I did not
have the highest expectations was not excited
for this in the least I will admit exceptional
The Shield open by Dawn was I dreading it
a little bit is it amazing yes it is what
the hell oh yes how is this all yeah I swear
style there's so many great I've got a bandana
unbelievable oh great poov nebula Nova Prime I'm
here to end this good choice in the handheld oh
good catch Ronin is entering the atmosphere as we
speak you can't stop this but it's not too late
to join me no I think it is Shields closing this
shows the importance of strong visuals because
that communicates so much emotion that you could
do it in an efficient amount of time and they've
rebuilt in a whole team in 20 minutes and made
us care about them it's taking the ships down
with it and improved Howard the Duck 10-fold oh
she's cutting him in half you trible crossed me
Triple Crossed actually I saw yon rocks move
a mile away so I put my little twist on the
code oh that's clever the moment you told
me to solve this by any means necessary I
knew you'd broken our oath still doesn't make
it hurt any less n it's over Nova Prime I'm
taking you in all of you we'll see about that
love how yr's a [__] again he's always that
guy except she was smart enough to see the twist
that the Marvels tried to make [Music] special
whoa you broke the a I don't think
it'd be that easy to break my first
nebula was so Glen Close to killing her
so Glen Close aren't you a big deal Betty
no
that's yeah oh yeah puny bdy some Hulk
smashing a this is so [Music]
cool I feel like xandar actually has
a personality yeah great shot god
damn yeah she's going to survive a
bit more than you there Glen Close
take my hand why could you just
join me I took an oath you ruined
everything dumbass cool awesome oh my God
and now they can open the doors let the I
mean I just pray to God we don't get a bunch
of idiots say woke culture [__] hey that's
a woman in power which can't happen it can't
if you keep the path Nova you can find your
way to the light well well if it isn't the
Supernova you blew up our Space Invaders
thanks to you the planet's actually getting
its life back and your liquor license is
safe I love how her actual delivery with people
matches her narration internal narration yeah the
Ness of her totally plays here usually there's a
contrast but I love how it matches so well that
was like Seth Green as Howard the Duck just Chang
game that was so good okay whoa well listen that
made me feel great I'm much more excited about
the rest of the season now and I'll tell you
what also makes me feel great are sponsors thank
you to Shopify for sponsoring which is what we
use for our merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in Ecommerce so whether you're launching
a passion project are scaling to new heights
Shopify is the e-commerce Powerhouse guiding
you at every step from creating your first online
store to opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seamless it's perfect whether you're selling
exclusive merch or unique Collectibles thanks
to their all-encompassing platform for both online
and in store sales their checkout system unmatched
it's 36% more effective at converting visitors
into buyers than other platforms and let's not
forget Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but seriously
reflecting on your journey using Shopify for www.
reation shop.com it's been transformative the
transition smooth growth exponential thank you
thank you again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify has been
a Cornerstone of our success and Shopify isn't
just for us owers 10% of us e-commerce backing
businesses big and small in over 175 countries
their award-winning support always there to guide
you so ready to join the revolution sign up for
Shopify at only a dollar a month at shopify.com
rejects all overc case shopify.com rejects start
your Shopify success story now let's grow together
with Shopify team big thanks to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video a real game changer
I've been using for years that's right years
so whenever they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about expressvpn
for online privacy and security but there's
more to it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum showing down
my internet and contacted me due to a suspecting
hacking attempt and funny enough I realized I
hadn't actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months ago so I
was paying the consequences having faced a serious
hacking issue on YouTube a couple years ago that
made expressvpn my go-to for both security and
freedom I mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you can use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows on Netflix
that are not available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema your fingertips
it's super easy open expressvpn switch locations
refresh the browser and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korea Netflix Hulu BBC I
player YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered
and it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience so
if you want to get access to hundreds of new
shows use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and
you can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn for
free that's expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com Rex to learn more thank you again
all right guys if you're listening to us on Apple
and Spotify we just watch what if episode one
of season 2 now before going into this both Co
and I were like it's what if you know it's kind
of on the lower end of the spectrum for us when
it comes to the rating the season one like there
were some couple of episodes that we quite loved
uh but overall as a whole and I feel like this
one episode my they already set a new bar for
what the rest of the episodes have to be uh with
this with this version of nebula I mean we said it
plenty of times during the reaction but in case
you decided just to skip the reaction which I
find very odd is like I I loved her portrayal of
how it contrasted so differently compared to what
we see her in live action they actually took
it a different direction it's not just a fun
hey what if we like body swapped or what if we
position swapped we actually made a a different
character out of her that also still made sense
based off the trajectory where we left off with
her at a certain point in time which is what they
did with Loki this felt like what they did with
Loki yeah exactly and that's what what ifs are
on the comics and that's why I didn't love the
what if season 1 as much because what if season
1 felt like it was like what if Peter Parker
took trigonometry I was like I don't care about
any of these ws and like it just didn't like do
enough for me and then like by the end I cared
because I did care about uh sorcerer Supreme I
cared about and then they didn't do anything with
it so I felt like you finally got me to Care by
the end of what if season one and then they like
ignored it and teased it and then didn't deliver
whereas this is the Loki thing where it's an
actual what if of grabbing a character we do
know and love and then just twisting them at a
point that we've already lived through exactly
exactly hold on I'm waiting to see really quick
if there's going to be something here at the
end it would seem not it would seem not all
right it stays in the video us waiting for a
post traumatic pause that's what the patrons get
every day that's our watching faces well the other
side of it too that I really loved was like we
know of xandar we know of these places H you know
we still call her Glen Close I don't even remember
her character name Glen but you know you take an
even though you're doing an alternate version of
them they still feel like they're actually making
them more of a character they still feel like
we're getting more of a personality behind them
and I really liked the Intrigue of it I mean
just overall the the overall nuances I spent
forever talking about what makes this one episode
better than most of what of season one just from
a season premiere point of view season premier
point of view directing upgrade animation upgrade
everybody when we did the review of the trailer
everybody was like it's the exact same animation
I was like no it no it's not no there's so much
more attention to detail and the movement Style
could be the same but like it's like you can do a
sketch or you can do an art like they went in they
kept adding and then the the DP of this the the
way this is shot the framing all that stuff the
way you introduce the season is this yeah like I
I remember being kind of okay about the the Peggy
Carter one of season one that was a Premiere and
but that's more of what I meant of yeah okay it's
it's Captain America but it's Peggy instead yeah
that's what I mean by that's not a what if comic
that's like all right you just changed characters
not what if that's all you really did and then
here we did a very different plot which all lowed
of cool Direction and even yonr like the limited
screen time you get here he's still got more of a
distinct personality than he does in the entirety
of Captain Marvel entirety of Captain Marvel and
the twist actually works better and then calling
out the twist works great because how obvious The
Twist wasn't Captain Marvel I found myself going
it would be really cool if this version of nebula
did somehow come to the live action yeah I would
love to see this version even her showing up with
the yond do Mohawk and the ER I didn't see any of
that coming that somehow I didn't either and then
all the great Guardians like you know comic cover
shots it was like it was so obvious which is
what I love when you go like of course they
were setting that up but I didn't think of it cuz
like the rock paper scissors joke I'm like that's
funny but then they made it the team and I was
like that would be an incredible team yeah and
that's that's the another thing even looking like
a comic book you know we said during the reaction
too is that this actually felt like I was looking
at a panel I kept comparing it to you know obvious
like sci-fi touches of anime and it's got cyber
Punk World Blade Runner animatrix animatrix Ghost
in the Shell things that Matrix were inspired by
like all the the derivative all the the or Boris
Matrix in anime there's reason Blade Runner yeah
all those like wonderful flourishes throughout
but it didn't just feel it actually inhabited
it instead of just paying homage to it yeah it
didn't feel like it was trying to take the style
it felt like it was in the style of yeah and
they Justified it storywise of how we got there
delivery I never even considered how nebula would
be great in no Noir such a funny like you know
when like kids are like who' win a fight Hulk
or Thor I've often done that with characters
since phase one of Marvel where I'm like what
genre would I want to see blankin you know since
they had so many genres I never considered Noir
nebula and it's so obvious and it makes sense
for her to be a detective like with her skill
that's what I mean they actually just used what
her skill set was they did what if they exactly
they just did oh yeah you know we could what would
be a cool genre it seemed like an apt genre to to
put insert her into this felt like a phase two
movie where they were like we've established the
characters we're going to change the genres around
we're going to enhance the characters it it didn't
make you have to relearn them it didn't do an
origin story because of where it took off and
that's why I think phase two is so strong I like
winter soldier more than First Avenger because
now we already know the characters now you can
try a new genre I like Guardians of the Galaxy
more than I like the First Avenger movie because
as much as I love The Avengers getting together
I was like these are characters I wouldn't have
expected to love and we're invested this did that
it's a phase two property where it's like dive
in take a pivot make a genre and be dope oh and
what they did too with I got one criticism and
I'll go into it uh breaking the arrow but the uh
the Whatchamacallit um uh what were we talking
about I interrupted you had one criticism and
I interrupt like an assho I wasn't that no that's
fine don't worry about the arrow I was so stressed
about how much we have to film today that like
I keep see you GL at I did not sleep cuz I was
like there's so much to do I can't sleep that's
not healthy um the what what was it called Batman
and uh I don't remember he wasn't in it there was
something there this all stays in the video ain't
cutting jack [__] out of this one uh Glen Close
uh Yan Rog uh nebula uh Howard the Duck um Howard
the Duck there it is Howard the Duck that's what
it was Howard the Duck it's a character who like
started off as a fun little Cameo and in a post
credit green loves him in real life and ask James
gun to play him okay I didn't know that and as it
progressed where you see a little bit more of his
appearances I was like yeah it's it's amusing
it's amusing but I kind of feel like the joke's
been done to death of Howard the Duck and here
they actually made him a real character and in
the comics Howard the Duck has a lot of point
it's like though bad writers don't know how to
write squirrel girl bad writers don't know write
Howard the Duck and they make them punch lines
bad writers don't have to make Deadpool and they
make Deadpool a Punch Line This is much like that
where it's like no no Howard the Duck actually
has a point like Howard the Duck can be great
and here he is and Seth Green got the assignment
like there's a reason Seth loves Howard the Duck
and this is like showcasing that it's like a Danny
deito kind of character yes you know and I I love
the portrayal of him it's Joe pesi and Lethal
Weapon yeah yeah yeah it's a little guy with
an attitude that's just trying to get through
cuz the back and forth too I thought they had
a great like this was paced better than most of
season 1 and the way how they're back and forth
of the dialogue with nebula's very you know
noirish uh dry delivery and then Howard the
duck's very expression delivery and ta like
about the people around him and then Groot
only did a couple lines because that's dry like
nebula but it added comedy they really balanced
who was on that team well yeah and when a day
and age when you got like animated properties
like spider-verse inin invincible and then you
know I'm but just speaking speaking in terms of
Aesthetics you know like the Teenage beut Ninja
Turtles animated movie those films uh have made
such an impact Puss and Boots and that I do
think they needed to up the aesthetic overall
because that there's so much that can happen in
Just Vibe and mood and emotion based off of how
something thing looks and feels agreed whereas
sometimes these Rush Marvel movies could stand a
benefit from letting their visual effects artists
really go to town because that could do a lot of
work for you that the writing may not be able to
have the time to dive into just like this the best
thing to happen of what if season 2 was a strike
the animators you know the animators got prob I
I don't think they wanted to put this out in the
time and I also think that the the episode that's
Christmas is probably always planned to come out
at Christmas but I do feel like giving this time
to really animate really flourish and so you said
animation aesthetic with those I was gonna go with
spiderverse and Invincible as being when you trust
in a comic property in an animated medium you can
really really adapt comic books in a better way
even then live action sometimes because you can
like do a characterization in a more unreal way
this wasn't trying to be photorealistic this
wasn't trying to be it was trying to be awesome
and follow the character's Journey which is what
I think Invincible does really well and they did
here yeah yeah for sure for sure man for sure my
one criticism that I would say is that um that
the I I liked what happens to xandar but there's
just something about the MCU that does not know
how to get Ronin down yeah like he's just not a
presence here no and also the xandar we felt was
a character but we didn't have any xandarians feel
like they were like changed I would have liked
another 2 minutes of like life on xandar under
the you know oppressive Darkness just a little bit
and then maybe you know uh uh what's his name you
just said it um yandu y yonr yonr uh just like
him you know scheming like I wanted a little bit
more villainy a little bit more you know that
direction but overall like this was exceptional
this is exceptional guys what did you think about
our first episode of what if leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a like
thank you to our sponsors let's end this with a
pat John pick name fev Doren FV you know what
we're going to get you for Christmas this year
we are going to get you a teleportation device
we need that for you for you specifically so
that way whenever it comes time to us watching
Hunter Hunter we teleport you into our bathroom
office yes so that way and we're going to lock it
so we can you can hear us through the wall you can
hear us and if we have a question we shout it at
you and whenever you show up in our bathroom the
toilet not okay yeah sure and the toilet won't be
working honestly didn't catch what John what' you
say I said you better have the answers because you
know calling on him for you know whatever we need
to ask him about so like I could care less about
that I really just want F trapped in the bathroom
while we're filming Hunter Hunter I think that'd
be hilarious sure yeah absolutely and none of the
facilities work there's no paper or you know
other uh hygiene products yeah so don't even
think about using that bad it's not for your
wellbeing and so it's not a practical Choice
what we're going to do then is while you're in the
bathroom you're going to get a Shard that slides
underneath through the bathroom slant oh every
10 minutes and you're going to be like what is
you're not going to be able to tell what this
Shard is you're going to get get little shards
at a time then eventually you're going to put it
together you're going to realize it's a Blu-ray
oh what's this blue it's a Blu-ray of Hunter
Hunter what they're not even watching the Blu
Ray I gave they're all in here and he's destroying
the Blu-rays yes feed it to me every time I go to
the bathroom that's your present man is I'm good
to torture you in our bathroom I give you up yeah
that's what you get for Holiday discs that's
what you get for for all your goodwi and your
encouragement of our watching experiences take
that FL your preservation CH bu you get locked
in a bathroom to suffer with nothing while you
listen to us have fun not even the sink works
so just sweaty and gross and I forgot a flush
and the mirror is broken so you can't even look
at yourself to contemplate Insanity it's just
a room you're just a Sol room man we're going
to torture you in solitary all you hear is Joy
happening outside and us getting Minor Details
wrong that could use more context only we want to
complain are we going to say it right up against
the bathroom door yeah of what we don't like
about this episode and you promised it would
be amazing and it's a oneway oneway audio room so
you can only hear us but can't hear you respond
can't hear you man two-way sound sorry about
it buddy but you can't hear you does that ex I
a bathroom that does that why would I why would I
want that for the bathroom I can hear them [__]
but they have no idea how loud they're being
I me the opposite but same same Theory where
somebody I would hate that too man Wonder like
someone slips and falls in the shower and I'm
like I can't hear you you devise this so that way
people can hear you [__] but you might be taking
a shower somebody breaks in you can hear them
but they can't hear that you're taking a shower
so you could sneak one over on them what John do
you have any idea how dangerous this is you very
it's not a good idea terrible I'm just saying like
does it exist unless there was like a way like the
way you enable it for like headphones like a noise
cancelling one yeah where you're like oh I enable
this do a noise cancelling bathroom installment
that I could like flick the switch like that would
actually be an amazing device who would not buy
that make a smart device you got would not knows
how to isolate your voice but can mix out all
of your bathroom sound there was a way where
you could like yeah where you like turn a switch
on that way you're guest when they have to poop
they may have noise cancelling they don't have
to worry about how loud they're being or my wife
doesn't have to worry about how loud I'm being
not that I give a crap about how loud I'm being
for so long like put your ear up against this door
you love me no matter [Laughter] what I'm going to
be abjectly disgusting no way is this going to
be okay if the rules are reversed I won't even
acknowledge this biological phenomenon happens
to you but who wouldn't buy that I feel like a
lot of people wouldn't buy but I would buy it I
would spend I would spend hundreds of thousands
of dollars yeah if you if you had a bathroom that
you could could easily like yeah mute the sound
or yeah again like mix out your bathroom s so if
you need to be on the phone or you need to like
call out the door people will just hear your
voice and nothing else that's why I love F he
keeps his creative he keeps those creative juices
flowing as he is a has to hold in his juices from
flowing while we watch Hunter Hunter that's the
trade that's the exchange anyway F Merry Christmas
buddy this is the best show I think we've done
all year yep we were holding it in to the very
end